All right, this is where it actually gets really interesting and a little bit whacky.
We just showed that if you a had a solution to SAT, you could use it to solve 3 colorability
and maybe that's not so weird because 3 colorability is about finding
some kind of a satisfying coloring and so we have the satisfying formula--not so weird.
Now, what we're going to do is the other direction to show that 3 colorability is NP hard.
We know it's an NP, but is it NP hard. If it's NP hard, it must be NP complete because it's an NP.
But to show that it's NP hard that means we have to take some NP hard problem
and solve it by way of 3 colorability.
That means we have to be able to take a satisfiability formula, somehow express it as a
graph coloring problem, and if we can do that, that means a solution to the graph coloring problem
resolves satisfiability and therefore, anything in NP.
I went and took a little bit of a short cut just so we can get to the punchline fast,
and we're only going to deal not with the full satisfiability problem which gives
any kind of boolean formula, but specifically 3-SAT.
3-SAT or just the satisfiability formulas have the form like so where the whole formula
is a bunch of ends of clauses, so it's clause end, clause end, clause end, clause end and so on
until all the clauses have been expressed.
Each clause itself is the or of three literals and the literal itself is either
a variable or a delegation of a variable and ???.
So you could have something that looks like X or not Y or z
and w or X or not z and that's a 3-SAT problem.
It's not a very hard 3-SAT problem, but it's a 3-SAT problem.
And with clauses, each clause has 3-literals, each literal has either
the name of a variable or not the name of a variable.
Now, just so happens that this problem is also NP hard, it's an NP complete,
just like satisfiability but it's a lot easier to work with.
So somebody walks up to us and says, "Well, I have a general satisfiability question."
It might be easier if they walked up to us and said, "I have a 3-SAT question."
Now, this is not easier in the computational complexity sense, it's just easier just working with it
and writing an algorithm sense, but the algorithm--the problem itself is equally hard.